thank you Yasser Maxim an important
victory for you but not an easy one in
fact it felt like at some point you
might have been even in trouble how did
you assess uh these games I thought
after I played this horrendous move G3 I
was the worse which I've seen now this
is absolutely true I was trying to find
a way to like get an advantage but you
know but the solution is much worse than
the than the problem so at this point
you were playing for an advantage yes
thought that you're better I thought I
could be better I thought I I can't I'm
not worse so what would I do to play for
an advantage I have to stop at four F or
to play G3 but then when he played Queen
E5 I was like oh my God but you invited
this Rook takes C3 you showed him hey
take only three
I was worried about Bishop E5 here that
was the movie I was really and probably
this was a much better resolution
because it just stops Rook F4 which is
my idea about Queen of three so now I
was thinking okay if I play like Queen
E2 then a number of moves Bishop D4
notably was what I noticed later and
then it's the main one yeah but F4 is
also pretty good but yeah yeah but uh so
so no Queen E2 but he took on E3
it was very surprising because I thought
I mean I could only I'm playing for win
now although yeah you weren't worried
about the weakness of your king I wasn't
I mean I I mean no not typical GM level
you like the material well first of all
I like material and secondly you know my
King has squares and you know the best
you can hope for some Perpetual so you
know why I want to just be in trouble
yeah Rook D5 was a mistake huh yeah yeah
yeah and then I was seeing you know
ideas like um
what would I play Queen C4 here no is
that what I played maybe yeah Queen's
four works as well
although there are animals but yeah now
I think the execution part was uh pretty
good very clean okay good thanks
thankfully yeah I didn't I didn't want
to play E4 because who knows but but
although you know obviously it's a good
move but like I'm like you know if I
take only four I want my queen to go
through eight so I played Rook C first
minimal difference yeah and then and
then I and then I'm like okay but this
is
I actually thought about playing A4
uh-huh before Rook survive uh but then
Bishop D6 I mean it's bad but it's like
at least so I was because that saves the
temple over the game right yeah not the
player but you know then I had to war
and like okay and you have to worry
about some transitions yeah who knows
who's faster but I've been doing some
studies lately and it moves like A4 prop
you know come in quite often so yeah
and it worked out just nicely after the
point of screening basically Max an
important victory for you with the black
pieces last year you made it
with the white pieces excuse me well
last year you made it tie breaks you
almost won the championship what is the
plan for this year and did you do some
training a lot of training before this
one I played one tournament uh
Philadelphia Open just stay open yeah
like in fact the game went first 12
moves went like in this game but then
eight moves later I won against than I
am so I was pretty much it but uh like I
won on 20 moves and so I was kind of
happy that you know I can still figure
out an attacking idea well Joel was
saying that he actually prepared for
every single participant before the
tournament did you do anything remotely
close to that I probably shouldn't say
because that would give away some stuff
but uh
[Laughter]
no just a congratulations uh Max I did
have uh one question because I I mean it
it had the appearance to me perhaps it
wasn't did you blunder it just this
moment I I mean okay uh objectively
probably it's equal but you have a
Superior Pawn structure right you have
the potential of creating a candidate
black is thinking Bishop H6 and rookie
four right right and so you went C4 yeah
he took it and he took another one yeah
you didn't blunder D4 no no no because I
mean no no I understood that you know
once once the Deep one's gone my Bishop
was alive and I can always win one of
the pawns uh so I should be at least
equal and probably at most equal but you
know right so I mean rather than playing
in your move Rook D1 and the sequence
went C for takes because the H1 is a is
a Target and and so is you know my queen
has to leave because Bishop H6 in there
yeah so so a move like for example uh
Queen F3 or something like this it takes
on F5
and then therefore is a threat and and
uh
and I couldn't understand why you mean I
would be okay here yeah I thought it
could be worse you I see okay yeah
Bishop F6 is also a threat so right at
the very least I'm gonna trade on G5 and
The Rook comes to E2 which is not what I
want not not ideal not ideal I mean
another way to play through it so I said
okay well I gotta get out of this uh
situation here gotcha all right uh nice
nice nice well a nice turn around and
good luck uh in your campaign thank you
yes absolutely absolutely three
decisions